friends forever or bitter Rivals here's
the lowdown on House of the dragon's
breakout Stars pathway through the first
season of The House of the Dragon the
show experienced a major time Jump and
while it no doubt had major implications
for all of the characters the two most
affected are rhaenyra Targaryen and
alicent Hightower that's because the two
actors who play them Millie Alcock and
Emily Carey have exhausted their story
arcs at least for now we'll see what
happens in season two episode six saw
Emma Darcy and Olivia Cook respectively
slide into their aforementioned roles as
characters raniera and Allison start off
as the best of friends before political
circumstances forced them into a more
complicated situation naturally given
how close their characters are that
might lead some fans to wonder whether
Alcock and Carrie are actually friends
in real life here's what they've said at
the time of season 1's release Alcock is
22 years old while Carrie is 19. both
have appeared in movies and TV shows
before Alcock made her name in several
TV series in her native Australia while
Kerry played young Diana in 2017's
Wonder Woman and young Lara Croft in
2018's Tomb Raider but for both young
actors their roles in House of the
Dragon are the biggest in their careers
by far being cast in a prequel to one of
the biggest Series in the history of
Television is an experience that few can
relate to because of that Alcock and
Kerry gravitated towards each other as
Carrie told the New York Times we're
very lucky in that we get along in real
life so the chemistry came very
organically we're quite like our
characters meanwhile Alcock explained
we're two very young women who haven't
done massive projects before in an
environment full of men having to live
up to this opportunity we were forced to
hang on to each other for dear life
being cast in the show was just one of
the many challenges for the young
actresses and not being able to speak
about it with anyone else made their
bond even stronger Kerry later told
e-news I see Millie as a big sister I
don't think that will ever diminish it's
such a strange Niche set experience and
the kind of thing that you can't really
talk about about with anyone else of
course the relationship between rhaenyra
and alicent doesn't stay so sweet the
pair's lifelong friendship is tested
when Allison's father Otto Maneuvers her
into becoming the new wife of King
viserys who also happens to be Rainier's
father
what anyone sees when they look at me
now is
[Music]
El reinero struggles with her father's
decision to name her his Heir
particularly the requirement that she
agreed to a political marriage not of
her choosing before long their
friendship has changed forever the
relationship between these two
characters is clearly complicated and
playing it is a unique acting challenge
but exploring such a complex Dynamic
made Alcock and Carrie admire each other
even more as Alcock told collider
there's something just really lovely
about getting to be someone who works
alongside an actor that you adore
there's something really nice about it
it's not a requirement that actors
playing friends actually be friends in
real life of course but in this case the
bond between Alcock and Kerry's
characters seems all the stronger for it
[Music]